ich bin heute Legolas dachte ich ma mir
so eine cute rich Frisur und se ich einf
nur aus wie Legolas Legolas was sieht
dein
Adlerauge oh wie dieses eine graue Haar
sich so
raussneakt dieses Video wird aufregend
ich bin jetzt schon sehr
aufgeregt denn wir haben ein braunes
Paket und ich liebe braune Pakete ihr
habt auf dieses Video geklickt ihr wisst
was hinter diesem braunen Paket sich
verbirgt wow als allererstes bekommt man
einen Beutel der hat eine ganz gute
Qualität oh Gott ich dachte schon es ist
ein Beutel es ist ein Beutel dieser
Kalender kostet 600 € und ist immer nur
noch die Hälfte vom sarowski Kalender
der Kalender ist so kacke dann packen
wir es mal aus ne ach ist der schön
dieser Beutel wird auf jeden Fall
behalten ich mach mir natürlich nicht
aus Marken ne nein der hat
Gummistopper wenn du den irgendwo
hinstellst
der bleibt bombenfest was ist mein Leben
was ist mein Leben ganz wichtig wir
ziehen mal hier die Folie
ab wow reiche Menschen brauchen ja auch
ein Adventskalender und die können ja
sicher nicht ein von Maybelline Jade
nehmen ich komme nicht drüber hinweg das
Teil kostet 600 € wir müssen das jetzt
mal alle kurz
verdauen und ich mache jetzt hier
einfach so weiter wie ich das immer tue
okay hol euch ein Tee ein Kaffee heiße
Schokolade
Entschuldigung bevor ihr denkt dass Dior
mich gesponsert hat dieses Video ist
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses
Video ist nicht gesponsert also wenn di
Social Media Marketing machen würde ne
dann wäre ich die erste Ansprechperson
für Sie sage ich euch kommen wir zu den
Adventskalender facts für die
vorweihnachtliche Zeit präsentiert das
Haus Dior einen zauberhaften
Adventskalender der die Fassade der
historischen boutik in der 30 Avenue
monta Montagen montagne nachbildet
Regisseur Regisseur eisverkeh beim
Öffnen zeigt er eine atemberaubende
Dekoration von Pietro rufo die zu einem
bezaubernden spazziiergang einlädt wow
genießt einmal hier den Gesamtlook wow
nee der Kalender ist wirklich super toll
verarbeitet also er ist mega stabil der
erste Eindruck ist perfekt man kann es
ja schon bisschen mit dem Swarowski
Kalender vergleichen einfach weil wir
Höhen Preiskategorie sind und hier muss
ich sagen hat man noch ein
hochwertigeres Gefühl als beim sowski
Kalender auch weil hier einfach nichts
rausfällt beim ersten aufmachen ich habe
hier meine Bewertung der Wert des
Kalenders übersteigt rechnerisch den
Preis um ca 100 € also man kriegt was im
Wert von 700 € und bezahlt 600 € Girl
math man hat richtig was gespart wir
fangen jetzt einfach mal an Türchen
Nummer 1 Gott
also hier sind zwei Sachen drin als
erstes haben wir ein
Buch das ist aber klein
nicht mal ein Druck drauf jador Dior das
bekannte Perfum aus dem Hause Dior ich
habe von diesem Perfum mal meiner Mutter
in Polen einen Dube gekauft also ein
Fake und dachte für ein Moment dass ich
ihr ein Dior parfü gekauft habe aber da
stand nicht mal Dior drauf
hä was ist das das ist weiß aber es
riecht gut oh mein Gott riecht das Gut
das riecht extrem gut ich weiß nicht was
das ist was ist das denn h das ist ja
doch ein perfüm ich verstehe gar nichts
es ist milchig aber es ist ein perfüm es
hat die zauberhafteste Größe aller
Zeiten in Türchen Nummer 2 gibt einen
Lippenstift ja eine
probegröße das ist ein roter Lippenstift
den probiere ich mal aus ja den verlose
ich euch mal ausnahmsweise nicht also
ich den hier z allerersten Mal
aus so fühlen sich iche Menschen sagen
wirlich ein ganz toller einzige Problem
war jetzt dass ich wirklich sehr ölige
Lippen habe also ich werde nicht
rumrechnen auf wie viel wir mit diesen
Produkten kommen ich möchte immer nur
wissen was die originalen Produkte
kosten velvet die Farbe
999 ja
41,99 € ich liebe diese Farbe in Türchen
Nummer 3 befindet sich bestimmt eine
Kerze das finden alle toll ne Amber n
eigentlich dürfte ich nie wissen was so
ein Kalender vorer kostet damit das
wirklich komplett unbeeinflusst bewerten
kann aber es riecht fantastisch die
riecht wirklich super es ist aus einem
sehr stabilen kalten Material ah die
große Kerze davon kostet 85 € Nummer 4
sogar auf diesem Papier steht Dior
lisserum das ist L Serum ein Anti-Aging
Serum für 30 ml 103 € ne das ist ein
Drittel also 30 € für diese kleine
Flasche ich liebe es ja bei QVC wenn die
Hände immer so eingecremt werden also
bitte bit
schön ich würde den Duft so beschreiben
wie ganz saubere Wäsche und eine alte
Dame die diese saubere Wäsche gerade in
den Schrank
[Applaus]
legt das sind wie die großen Flaschen
nur in ganz klein den MA ich bitte
normal aber weniger cringch nur in ganz
klein m Dior blooming bouet ich kann es
nicht riechen ich glaube weil hier alles
gerade nach diesen diordüften riecht
neutralisiert sich das
gegenseitig das sch nur Alkohol spontan
mein geruchsind verloren der riecht so
leicht ganz leicht blumig aber tolle
Flasche wirklich sehr schön Nikolaus
dieser Kalender wird weltweit vertrieben
ich habe in diesem Buch nicht mal eine
deutsche Anleitung gefunden also denke
ich mal scheißen sie auf Nikolaus und
das ist okay das ist nee Nikolaus ist
ein großes
Türchen okay das muss Zufall sein gerade
jemand an der Tür ist ich habe nur ein
Hausschuh an Scheiße hi hab ihr angenmen
ja oh nein wie peinlich ich hatte nur
einen Schuh an und dann lag das Paket
vor meinen Füßen und dann muss ich an
meinem einen Schuh vorbei zum Paket
greifen s aber schön überspielt okay wo
waren wir ich hoffe die haben noch ein
Puder oder so ne ich brauche hier noch
ein bisschen was gegen meinen Glanz
Nummer se ist doch ein Nikolaus Geschenk
das sehe ich
doch ich dachte das ist ein Schmuckstück
was ist das denn was ist das D der Stern
sieht ja toll aus ne wirklich ist ist ja
ein schöner Stern und für Tannenbaum
bestimmt auch eine super Idee und was
von Dior wenn man Dior Fan ist alles
super aber was ist denn bitte diese
Schnur das sieht aus als ob das jemand
in einem Schulprojekt selbst gebastelt
hätte um es auf dem Adventsbasar zu
verkaufen hät zu viel Arbeit gekostet da
oben noch ein Loch auszustanzen und dann
einfach eine Schnur da reinzustecken
statt das so zu machen das sieht so
sieht so falsch aus aber die Schachtel
war schön Nummer
7 noch ein Perfum es gibt sehr viele
perfüme hier gris Dior das für Männer ja
ist es für Männer 40 ml kosten 130 € gr
ist ein intensiver zypreduft für Damen
und Herren und wer macht Werbung für
grriis Dior mein
[Musik]
Dubel also Dior wenn ihr schon jennaer
nimmt dann braucht ihr für den deutschen
Markt gar nicht weiter suchen ihr habt
das neue Dior model gefunden gris Dior
riecht für beide gut eins ist sicher ich
werde diesen Dezember sehr gut riechen
sehr gut in Nummer
8 befindet sich die absolut neutralste
Nagellackfarbe die man sich auftragen
kann aber es von Dior deswegen macht es
ganz besonders toll kine eine Flasche
Dior nail polish kostet 31 € ist das
super okay nachdem Nikolaus ja schon so
toll war freuen wir uns extrem auf das
Türchen Nummer 9 Türchen Nummer 9 ist
nämlich mein lieblingstürchen als meine
lieblingszah ist okay das wird jetzt
hier richtig klasse ich hätte gerne ein
bisschen mehr was fürs Gesicht wo ist
Johnny DEB holt ihn
[Musik]
raus ist ganz schön viel perfüm für so
ein
Adventskalender das ist ja ein toller
Männerduft den soll Timo
tragen ich lieb es ich finde den Duft
richtig gut richtig richtig gut aber
sehr ernüchterndes neuntes Türchen
Männerduft hey so warsch wird einem
hinterher geworfen 30 ml für 70 € Nummer
10 eine Kerze boah die riecht auch
fantastisch
Scheiße habe ich jetzt mal so ganz
selbstbewusst gesagt und ihr glaubt mir
einfach mal dass es so heißt zu den
Adventssonntagen packen sie Kerzen rein
finde ich in Ordnung boah das eine
krasse
Kombi ja das das ist wunderbar aber
nicht dass sie dann am 24 auch eine
Kerze rein machen weil dieses Jahr ist
der 24 20 auch der vierte Advent das
kann man den echt nachsagen ne also für
die 600 € bekommt man einen gut
duftenden Raum Nummer 11 ist das das
sieht so hübsch und teuer aus wie so
kleine Bläschen ein Serum für face und
neck waren wahrscheinlich schon 3 € die
ich gerade rausgespritzt habe du und
Serum für Nacken kann ja nichts kann ja
nicht schaden ein paar Sekunden
später was ist das was sind das denn
immer für Produkte
für Preise und ich habe mir da kiloweise
gerade auf de Nacken mit drauf
geschmiert 15 ml kosten 155 € hier sind
10 ml drin 100 € kostet diese Flasche
was ist da drin 100 € dafür kriegt man
ganze Adventskalender also ja was macht
es feuchtigkeitsspenden Anti-Aging
pflegend und reparierend Saison Herbst
du das werde ich diesen Herbst aber
gerne benutzen gut gemacht di da merkt
man das ist eine andere Welt
Nummer 12 und wir sind in der Halbzeit
passend zum Lippenstift in der gleichen
Farbe der Nagellack in 999 woW ist ein
tolles rot ne riecht das auch nach
Dior nein das stinkt nach normalen
Nagellack ganz normaler stinkender
Nagellack aber da steht Dior drauf
deswegen ist es was ganz besonderes und
super toll 13
Jasmin
eisverkeh total lustig weil ich kann
kein Französisch ich rieche den Duft
nicht wenn ich aus der Flasche versuche
zu riechen ja gut aber ich stinke jetzt
auch bra irgendeine Körperstelle die ich
noch nicht eingeschmiert habe der riecht
auch gut riecht aber als ob der für
meine Mama
wäre Nummer 14 ich präsentiere noch ein
Nagel okay mein Hirn hat gerade komplett
aufgehört zu funktionieren ein
Lippenstift in Rot ein anderes rot mit
viel mehr Braunanteil und viel dunkler
es ist gar nicht das Gleiche rot das ist
überhaupt was anderes müsste mal
vielleicht den alten abmachen kann sogar
vorstellen dass der dunkle mir ein
bisschen besser
steht jetzt merke ich wie der sich
eigentlich auch anfühlen müsste weil ich
hatte vorhin so ein bisschen Öl noch auf
meinen Lippen bevor ich den roten
Lippenstift drauf gemacht habe das sch
angalt wow ich finde die Farbe toll die
ist auch ganz anders als die andere
Farbe 15 oh lamous off on foaming
Cleanser also ganz ehrlich das ist ja
Dior ne und schön und gut aber die
Packung sieht an sich einfach extrem
billig aus mach jetzt auch nicht auf das
gebe ich euch natürlich das ist ein
Cleanser für euer Gesicht und das packe
ich natürlich in die
verlosungsbox da hinten in diesem
aufbewahrungsding sammel ich Produkte
aus den adventskalenderv Videos
eigentlich die meisten die ich da
auspacke und Mitte November fange ich
dann an die Adventskalender die ich
dadurch dann selber verpacke auf
Instagram zu verlosen also folgt mir
gerne auf Instagram um das nicht zu
verpassen und einen selbstgemachten
malwan Adventskalender zu bekommen und
vielleicht bekommst du ja dieses Dior
foaming Mous Ding in Nummer
16 da haben wir es genau dieses Parfüm
habe ich meiner Mutter mal geschenkt als
ich klein war so 11 12 Jahre alt so alt
ist das schon und das hier ist mal nicht
mit Milch gemischt aber ich sag euch
ehrlich das Parfüm was ich meiner Mutter
geschenkt habe bra genauso so ein
bisschen ich so intensiv riechen keine
Anleitung man verteilt sich so das auf
sein Bein also so wenn ihr bei Douglas
seid dann müsst ihr das so machen und
dann riecht ihr dran und sagt ja das ist
jador Dior 17 kommt 7 Tage nach der 10
und was war vor einer Woche der Advent
der zweite und wir sind beim dritten
Advent ich glaube ich ma dieses Jahr so
ein classic Adventskalender mit so
diesen vier Kerzen und dann ja freue ich
mich the osmantus warum finde ich das so
frech von dir dass sie das so farblich
machen irgendwie passen diese farblichen
Kerzen überhaupt nicht zu diesem weißen
schlichten ich bin Christian Dior ja
riecht halt auch gut ne 18 das ist mir
hier zu viel what das war jetzt drin und
das hatten wir schon wo soll da der
Unterschied sein oder Perfum blooming
Bouquet was ist denn der
Unterschied also das war dieses
blumenzeug was so ganz schwach gerochen
hat ey ganz ironisch ne ich mache mir
das hier auf meine Aug ich rieche auf
meinen Händen nichts mehr das ist voll
mit 300 Seren ja das riecht halt
bisschen intensiver als dieses blooming
bouet aber ich keine Ahnung was der
Unterschied ist nur ist nicht so meins
ganz ehrlich riecht wie ein teenagerdft
schade schade ja in Nummer 20 befindet
sich der Dior
Mascara also ich find es sehr gefährlich
so teuren Mascara auszuprobieren denn
wenn es einem gefällt dann vergleicht
man man die billigeren immer mit dem
teuren und merkt dass alle anderen
schlechter sind ich habe das mir jetzt
mit dem Klinik Mascara der Klinik
Mascara ist für mich einfach der der für
mich am besten funktioniert aber ich
kann mir nicht ständig für 30 € Mascara
kaufen deswegen bleibt es immer nur eine
schöne Erinnerung das Ding wirkt hier
schon sehr hochwertig aber auch
eigentlich sehr schwach also ich kann da
so rüber Streifen rüber Streifen und da
verklummt nichts ja sieht sehr elegant
aus oder was sagt ihr elegante Wimpern
nicht so vollgeklumpt nicht so
übertrieben was kostet so ein Dior
Mascara uh der wird ja ein fast
hinterher geworfen
3799° im Angebot bei Douglas wow
oh nur noch vier Türchen also den könnte
ich wirklich den ganzen Tag Auspacken
21 was eine Handtasche nein schon wieder
diese Flasche wie oft kann man die noch
bekommen ich hasse dass das hier
überhaupt kein Label oder nichts drauf
ist ich meine auf diese klein Dinge
haben sie es doch auch geschafft dieses
mis Dior da drauf zu machen und hier ist
es einfach sieht aus wie so ein Fake
davon ja riecht auch wie eine Variante
von diesem Parfüm sehr viel Parfüm
22 y noch ein perfüm mein Gott sehen
diese perfüflaschen langweilig aus ja
rie wie ein perfüm in der Verlosung wird
es dieses Mal viele perfüme geben
vorletztes Türchen aber das vorletzte
Türchen ist riesig in Nummer 23 befindet
sich eine intensiv reparierende Creme
das ist so ein cooler Deckel irgendwie
der verändert sich je nachdem wie man
drauf schaut und auch hier das also das
optische und das haptische also wie es
sich auch in der Hand anfühlt da merkt
man schon das ist eine 10 von ze ja die
Creme fühlt sich sehr reichhaltig an
aber am Ende ist es auch nur eine Creme
so die la Creme hier sind 15 ml drin
dieses Teil kostet 1232 €.
oh genau das ist eine Fullsize so wir
sind jetzt durch unsere Adventstage
gekommen und wenn mich nicht alles
täuscht dann müsste jetzt in der 24 eine
Kerze drin sein was ein bisschen komisch
wäre ehrlich gesagt das ist drin hier
steht die Adresse drauf ich glaube bei
Dior geht's auch einfach nur darum dass
man sich so reich fühlt wie man auch ist
dass man das bloß niemals vergisst ich
bin reich ich habe mir ein Kalender für
600 € gekauft und mache jetzt hier meine
cented candle auf wo natürlich alles mit
Gold foliert ist love
Gold klar ich darf wirklich auch bei
keinem Zentimeter vergessen dass ich
reich bin und hier haben wir das Grand
Finale oh das riecht wie ein Spa sie
sind sich ihrem Motto treu geblieben an
den Sonntagen Kerzen zu machen und als
kleines Weihnachtsgeschenk gab es ja
vorher schon die Creme in der
Originalgröße für 132 € deswegen darf es
am 24 eine Kerze sein meiner Meinung
nach Bo die riecht extrem gut ich bin
sehr überrascht dass ich nach 24 Türchen
mit 24 verschiedenen Düften keine
Kopfschmerzen habe oder das Gefühl habe
oh mein Gott ich muss hier mal rausgehen
ich kann immer noch alles gut riechen
meine Beine riechen jetzt zwar nach 30
verschiedenen Düften meine Hände auch
aber ich finde ich rieche gut ich rieche
reich und das ist erstmal das wichtigste
an dieser Geschichte hier kommen wir zur
Optik ze von ze dieser Kalender sieht
einfach klasse aus der fühlt sich klasse
an wenn ich mir vorstelle dass man sich
jeden Tag so ein Türchen aufmacht und
dann wieder so zu und dann steht da auf
deinem 30.000 € Regal aus Echtholz
Mahagoni und dann steht da dieser
Kalender drauf das passt du bist reich
genuso sollte es aussehen
inhaltlich sind tatsächlich zu viele
Parfüme neun Parfüme ja so hat sich ein
bisschen angefühlt wie ein
perfümkalender wo andere Sachen noch
drin sind Nagellack haben wir sonst zwei
Lippenstifte von den Lippenstiften hätte
ich viel mehr da hättet ihr es voll
knallen können und ein Mascara und ein
Serum für 100 € das dürfen wir auch
nicht vergessen aber dieses Teil werde
ich in meinem Leben nicht vergessen das
ist so super liebes Dior Team wer sich
dafür entschieden hat mit dieser Schnur
ich weiß nicht ob i so ein bisschen auf
bodenständig selbstgebastelt machen
wolltet das wirkt danach macht's nicht
noch mal ihr seid nicht bodenständig und
auch nicht handmid selbst gemacht würde
ich mir diesen Kalender noch mal kaufen
h da muss ich jetzt erstmal
überlegen auf gar keinen Fall ja der
kostet halt 600 €. wenn du gerade
richtig frisch bei deiner Partnerin oder
deinem Partner verkackt hast so richtig
verkackt hast dann hol ihr den oder ihm
den Dio Adventskalender ich sag's euch
ganz ehrlich diesen Kalender nur gekauft
um einmal zu fühlen wie es sich anfühlen
würde und es fühlt sich gut an ich wäre
gerne reich aber jetzt kann ich die
nächsten Wochen so tun als ob ich es
wäre und mein 100 € Serum mir aufs
Gesicht schmieren ja nee ich empfehle
den nicht was soll ich euch sagen
natürlich empfehle ich euch den nicht
dieses Video war einfach nur ein Witz
das war eine Show ich habe euch an der
Nase herumgeführt und mich selber auch
wofür war dieses Video jetzt gut wir
wissen es nicht tschüssi wir sehen uns
dann das nächste Mal wieder habe euch
ganz ver lieb